what composition I mean that what
composition is their composition
hey guys it is Wednesday and it's great
so once every Wednesday for short or
it's been a long time since I've done a
favorites video so today I'm doing a
favorites video let's just start it
first thing this you see acts yeah yeah
trouble make a bag
I've been traveling a lot for our travel
webseries hey USA please go check out
you should have come so sash nuts on a
TV and trifle bags especially travel
makeup bags have been awesome and guess
what they come in cute designs I go
through travel makeup bag so crazy
because I use them and abuse them just
like men except these ones don't have
emotional recall I got this one at
Target by Sonia Kashuk this it's got a
design that looks like a snake
she hates snakes in real life but I love
them when they they are designed really
cute like on a makeup bag and this
makeup bag came with two other tiny
makeup bags inside it's like those
Russian dolls for makeup bags and this
was a price next this you stay AK you
say okay yeah it's a makeup sponge mmm
I've recently gotten into the trend that
his makeup sponges I am married cave
manic when it comes to putting on my
makeup I apply like a caveman in a very
manic fashion and I fight with my
fingers instead I've recently found that
you didn't apply foundation to a makeup
sponge and then company necks that you
say I say I say I'm speaking of a ways
to apply makeup this is makeup welcome
to makeup this is Smashbox Studios skin
15 hour hydrated foundation I love this
I was on a shoot one day and the makeup
artist used this on my skin and the
shoot last see you made eight hours
maybe and it didn't go anywhere the
makeup was like a well trained child you
don't train children you
how do you do children this is fantastic
it looks really natural doesn't look
like there's stuff on your face
and it lasts all day I've been wearing
it on hey USA almost every single day
that we shoot and even though it's hot
and sweaty it still holds up and I love
it very very much thank you
we're saying thank you do next yeah yeah
just yeah if you see a travel containers
and this might seem so Bobby is but
lives should grant for travel this is
called a gravity feed bottle okay
gravity feed bottle makes me sound like
a toddler in space I just think they're
really helpful because I constantly
constantly put over sized lotions or
sprays or stuff like that in my bags and
then when I get through TSA they show it
to me and they shamed me so hard and
then they forced me to throw away the
thing that I didn't even have a chance
to love there's TSA stand for those she
[ __ ] just can't even keeping a safe
net this you see a key staff case yeah
Cooper II I've talked about this too
much to the point that you think I'm
sponsored by it and I'm not I'm just
talking a good product this is a good
product it just works it just works
essentially it's a spray that you can
spray before after you destroy a toilet
and the people around you and it
diffuses the scent and I thought it was
witchcraft and then I used it and it's
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is bitchin
what mmm yes you stay a few say that
kiss yeah that's good there's no what
you say about them if you watched any of
hey OSA you can see that memory and I
wear headscarves constantly because we
are in different environments we have
early call times and we don't like to do
our hair and head scarves can make it
look like you put in an effort when
really you did not next this bag you see
stay happy sad I know this person hmm
for $25 to me he looks way more
expensive it's not all the space inside
its we comparable you could probably fit
like at least a soccer ball in here
we'll cover some piece at least seven
Coke Zero is one of those bags of adult
diapers I bought it I showed up hanging
out with memory one day with the purse
she was like that's a great purse would
you get I say to number 25 dollars next
day she showed up with the black version
of this classic memory next and last
mask easy access damn Betsy corn nuts I
had this in a gift basket from someone I
forget who williams-sonoma the
coordinates
they are chili lime Inca corn nuts
historic corn nuts it's basically taking
what could be conceived a trashy snack
and making it elegant upper-class white
trash that's ever my favorites for July
I don't know here's a website favorite
Grace's guidebook calm did you forget
that I wrote a book and then it's
available for pre-sales I mean it's not
fully finished I'm in the second draft
of it which is insane but I'm in love
with it and I hope that you love it too
because this book is really into
polygamy having more than one partner
chris is guidebook